Many films have been made about Elvis Presley,
but Baz Luhrmann's 2022 biopic is the first
to tackle the King's lonely final years.
Baz Luhrmann's elaborate, often anachronistic
visual panache always gets a lot of attention,
whether he's depicting 1890s Paris or 1920s New
York. Elvis is no exception, with its whirling
roulette wheel camerawork and hip hop remixes of
Presley songs. But the film's most daring conceit
is arguably the way it tells the story of Elvis
from the vantage point of Colonel Tom Parker,
played by Tom Hanks under a mountain of
prosthetics and a thick Dutch accent.
Parker looks back on his life with The King as
he lies dying in a Vegas hospital bed in 1997,
wandering through a spectral casino
as the memories come flooding back.
"I am the man who gave the world Elvis Presley."
Over the years since Presley's death, Parker
has widely come to be seen as a villain,
manipulating his one and only client's trust and
taking far more than his share of the profits.
Luhrmann's film doesn't disagree with this
version of the facts, but in Parker's mind
he is Elvis' other half, the carnival barker to
his sideshow freak, the snowman to his showman.
"Col. Tom Parker was a carny, pure and simple."
The film's most compelling tension is between
the blameless, almost victimized way Parker
sees his own relationship with Elvis
compared with what we the audience see
happening on screen. This tension is exposed
early in the film with a brief flash to 1974,
when Elvis collapses backstage before
a concert and Parker makes it perfectly
clear that the only thing that matters is
that he gets back on his feet and performs.
As the film enters its final act, we revisit
that moment in 1974 when Presley collapses
with added context. At this point, Elvis has
been performing at the International Hotel
in Las Vegas for years due to the fact that
Parker signed him into essentially a lifetime
contract in exchange for the forgiveness
of Parker's massive gambling debts.
"If I was you, I would book
him for a hundred years."
"Well, no better time than the present."
Parker has also been promising
Presley his first global tour,
going back to the 1968 comeback special, only to
continually delay the start of the tour for one
reason or another. The truth finally comes to
light just moments before The King collapses:
Parker keeps delaying the tour because
he came to the United States illegally
and doesn't have a passport. His name isn't
even Tom Parker, nor was he ever a colonel.
"But I hear rumors that Colonel is an alien."
After his collapse, Presley is given a shot of
amphetamines to get him up and going again for
the show. He takes the stage, inebriated
and incensed by his manager's betrayal,
and in spectacularly dramatic fashion, fires
Parker in the middle of his performance.
"You are fired. You are fired. You're fired!"
It's a deeply satisfying moment, even if it is
nothing more than a fantasy. According to Elvis
biographer Alanna Nash, Presley and Parker's
professional falling out occurred after a show,
not in the midst of one, and for a completely
different reason. Furthermore, Parker's immigrant
status wouldn't come to light until after
Presley's death; there is no evidence that The
King ever suspected that Parker was anyone other
than the West Virginia native he claimed to be.
Parker's countermove, however, is accurate
to real life. After being fired by Presley,
Parker retires to his office and drafts an invoice
for unpaid promotional work dating back to 1955,
totaling over $8 million. According to
Nash, this is based on a real incident,
though the exact dollar amount
of the invoice is unknown. Elvis'
father Vernon breaks the news to his son
that Parker's bill would bankrupt them.
"We're gonna lose Graceland."
Elvis, furious, storms out of his suite,
only to find Parker waiting for him outside.
The two men argue viciously. Elvis gnashes
teeth and threatens to kill Parker;
the Colonel in turn belittles Presley's
career, reminding him, unfairly but honestly,
that the comeback special audience that loved
him so much was a plant, prompted to cheer by
a flashing "applause" sign. The scene is in
many ways the climax of the film, and Butler
and Hanks give it their all. Hanks delivers
the film's theme in this scene, declaring,
"We are the same, you and I. We are two odd
lonely children, reaching for eternity."
His entreaty falls on deaf ears as Elvis
walks out of the Colonel's life forever.
The film fades to black with a title card: "One
Year Later." Suddenly it's 1975 and Elvis is
now a media curiosity, a real-life version of the
sideshow act Parker always considered him to be.
"The colonel dressed up the hotel
like a carnival. There were posters,
teddy bears, and hound dogs all over the place."
He's gained weight. He's separated from his
wife Priscilla and rarely sees his daughter
Lisa Marie. And when he's not performing
in Las Vegas he's holed up like a hermit
at Graceland. There is one glimmer of hope,
as talks are apparently ongoing to have him
star with Barbra Streisand in a remake of A Star
is Born, but we know it will never come to be.
On the tarmac alongside the private jet
he named after his daughter, Elvis and
Priscilla have a tender conversation.
Like most of the dialogue in the film,
its primary focus is to establish for us the
state of Elvis' life and career in this moment,
and what his dreams and goals are. Elvis still
wants to make one good movie, after dozens of
cheap musicals, and worries that nothing he's
done will amount to anything when he dies.
"Nobody's gonna remember me. I've
never done anything lasting."
The film presents this as Elvis' final
conversation with his ex-wife, although,
in reality, he would live for another two years.
From that scene on the tarmac, the film skips
ahead two years to the announcement that Presley
has been found dead in Graceland at age 42.
Rather than try to recreate the spectacle of
Elvis' funeral procession or the massive
outpouring of public grief that followed,
Luhrmann uses archival footage of the real
thing. He also includes an audio excerpt
from President Jimmy Carter's statement
on Presley's death, in which he said,
Not too shabby for a kid who scandalized
the nation just two decades earlier.
In choosing not to recreate Elvis'
funeral, the film also skips over the
fact that Parker reportedly wore a Hawaiian
shirt and baseball cap to the service and,
while there, tried to strike deals with
mourners, according to biographer James
Dickerson. We'll never know whether his behavior
came out of callousness, sociopathy, denial,
or some misguided sense of showmanship,
just to keep everyone talking about him.
Butler up as the so-called "fat Elvis," but
here the young actor is decked out in wide
pair of jowls and double chin, mumbling and
stumbling as he sits down at the piano and
belts out an emotional rendition of the
Righteous Brothers' "Unchained Melody."
Sweat pouring down his face, the camera
stays tight on Butler in an intimate,
slightly uncomfortable way. It's different from
the way any of the film's previous musical numbers
have been shot, but soon we understand the reason
why, as Luhrmann cuts from Butler as Elvis to
footage of The King himself singing, accompanied
by a short montage of the real-life Elvis in many
of the situations we've seen dramatized in the
film. It's an emotionally affecting transition,
as we see just how accurately Luhrmann and Butler
have recreated so many moments in Presley's life.
It's also a reminder of just how powerful Elvis'
voice and presence were, even in his final days.
He gives a showstopper performance at that piano,
and the audience hangs on every note. We still do.
In the end, Elvis can't speak for himself, so
Parker does it for him, as he did for most of
their life together. Parker ponders who or what
killed Elvis as he shuffles about his purgatorial
casino floor in a hospital gown, dragging
an IV pole. It wasn't the pills and drugs,
administered by doctors who should have known
better, enabled by Parker, Vernon, and Presley's
whole entourage, the so-called "Memphis Mafia,"
who were all complicit in working Elvis to death.
"What can you do for him, Dr. Nick?"
And it wasn't Parker's greed and
mismanagement of Elvis' business,
which forced him to continue performing
at an unforgiving pace for years;
Parker is all too quick to absolve
himself of that responsibility.
"I didn't kill him.
I made Elvis Presley."
No, of course, it's we who killed Elvis, with
our relentless love for him and his inability to
say no. Parker's monologue here is a fascinating
moment in the film; Luhrmann and Hanks keep Col.
Parker at arm's length, unwilling to tell the
audience how we should feel about him. Instead,
they let the dying Dutch carny, the
"snowman," snow us to the very end.
After the screen fades to black, we get a series
of post-scripts filling us in on how the saga
of Elvis and the Colonel played out in the years
after Presley's death. The film takes liberties in
regard to what Presley and the rest of the world
knew about Parker's background. In real life,
it would be 1980 before it would be confirmed
that Parker was of Dutch descent and entered
the country illegally as a 30-year-old man.
Eventually, though, Parker's financial malfeasance
would come to light, and, in 1982, after a series
of lawsuits filed by Elvis Presley Enterprises,
a judge ruled that Parker had no legal
claim to any part of the Presley estate.
In his final two decades, Parker spent his days
in Las Vegas, puttering around one casino floor
or another, pouring his immense wealth down
the drain. He made few public appearances or
statements, emerging from the shadows only on
rare occasions such as the 1993 release of the
Elvis postage stamp. Presley, meanwhile, far from
the forgotten lounge singer he feared he'd become,
remains an international superstar nearly 50 years
after his death, and one of the highest-earning
dead celebrities of all time. His life and
work still inspire admiration and controversy.